[Musique]
après Manille et hameaux c'est au
Vésinet qu'il faudra désormais lever le
pied à partir du 1er janvier la vitesse
dans les rues sera limitée à 30 km/h ce
changement a pour but d'améliorer la
sécurité routière de réduire les
nuisances sonores et de permettre une
meilleure cohabitation avec les piétons
et cyclistes les routes départementales
restent quant à elle à 50 km/h le
porte-monnaie des mentais va être mise à
rude épreuve en 2023 pour faire face à
l'inflation et la hausse des tarifs la
ville de Mantes-la-Jolie va réévaluer de
3,5%, la quasi-totalité de ces tarifs
municipaux cela concerne par exemple la
localisation des salles communales
l'accès au lieu et activités culturelles
ou encore les concessions funéraires une
erreur administrative qui coûte cher à
l'AS Poissy en une semaine le club qui
était sur le podium du groupe A de
National 2 a perdu 7 points sur le
nouveau classement publiée par la
Fédération Française de foot en cause
les certificats médicaux figurants sur
les demandes de licence 2022-2023 de
deux joueurs qui ne présenteraient pas
les garanties d'authenticité nécessaire
la commission régionale de discipline à
donner gains à Rouen avec qui laisse
Poissy à disputer un match le 10
septembre dernier en leur donnant la
victoire sur tapis vert avec quatre
points en moins pour Poissy le club
c'est également vu retirer un point en
moins pour les trois rencontres
précédentes Rennes Blois et Granville le
club pourrait faire appel de la décision
plus que quelques jours avant le
réveillon de Noël et si certains d'entre
vous se demandent déjà comment se
débarrasser de son sapin après les
festivités le calendrier de la collecte
des sapins naturels a été donnée dans
plusieurs villes à Guyancourt le
ramassage se fera le 9 janvier 2023 le
10 janvier pour Montigny-le-Bretonneux
les deux villes mettent également à
disposition des lieux de collecte à
partir du 26 décembre les collectes en
porte-à-porte seront supprimés pour la
plupart des villes de la communauté
d'agglomération Versailles Grand Parc au
profit des lieux de collecte plus de
renseignements sur le site Internet de
votre ville et enfin pour ceux qui
seraient inquiets quant au bon
déroulement de la tournée du Père Noël
pas de panique le maire de la ville de
Beynes vient de signer un arrêté les
bancs de recharge électrique de la ville
seront exclusivement réservés au Père
Noël dans la nuit du 24 au 25 décembre
décembre toutes les personnes
stationnées en devant les bornes verront
leur véhicule transformés en traîneaux